herb kempkens wir haben es gerade
gesehen ein flug konnte nicht pünktlich
starten wegen dieser demonstration jetzt
mal ganz platt die frage dürfen die das
also ist das demonstrationsrecht covert
das sozusagen solche probleme nein das
tue das nicht denn das ist ja ein ganz
sensibler bereich wir müssen uns mal
vorstellen
das war in diesem so genannten push back
moment das heißt die maschine steht ja
so mit dem los in verfahren am gateway
und das wird dann durch so ein
spezielles fahrzeug wird ja so ein
flugzeug dann rückwärts zurück geschoben
das nennt sich push back und genau in
dieser phase ist das passiert das ist
natürlich höchst sensibel da werden also
auch die anderen flügel müssen ja auch
diese flugvorbereitung reagieren
die stewardessen die piloten sind unter
druck und wenn so eine aktion
tatsächlich dazu führt dass es zu einer
gefährdung der sicherheit des
flugverkehrs kommt dann ist das strafbar
und zwar wegen gefährdung des
flugverkehrs und das ist eine es
erschaffen auch nach dem deutschen
strafrecht und haben wir sogar binde
strafen ab sechs monaten freiheitsstrafe
bis zu zehn jahren das wird also sehr
scharf von den strafgerichten verurteilt
haben die müssen sich auf ein bisschen
was gefasst machen habe ich richtig
verstanden das jahr
wir haben allerdings ja auch die aussage
von eur wings das ist also nicht zu
einer gefährdung geführt hat so dass
dieser strafrechtliche bereich
vielleicht hier noch nicht überschritten
ist das müsste man mal sehen aber auf
jeden fall haben auch den
zivilrechtlichen bereich denn die
flugzeuge kommen ja verspätet an
und das führt zu weiteren kosten denn
die es muss der flughafen gebühren
seitens der gesellschaft bezahlt werden
natürlich auch die kerosinkosten und
dann haben wir noch die mitreisenden die
mitreisenden kommen später so also in
dem in dem zielflughafen an
und wenn der folgeschäden verursacht
werden dann kann es durchaus sein dass
diejenigen die ihr den flugverkehr
stören dass auch noch zahlen müssen also
das heißt das ist tatsächlich eine
riskante aktion sowohl strafrechtlich
als auch zivilrechtlich